there's a whole industry of people who
make a good living trying to make you
think you're insane
well I make a very good living reminding
you that you're not you think that once
the people gaslighting you on a daily
basis have been revealed to be Liars
come on people just get the shot
they would pump the brakes but
apparently some people are just addicted
to being dicks you're not worried that
the the 5G chip that it puts in you is
going to interfere with the 3G chip from
the last one Bill Gates and I decided
we're going to take the chips out now
we're not going to oh really go get shot
it's dope you have absolutely debased
yourself doing the dirty work for the
NIH doing the dirty work for
pharmaceutical companies dancing around
like a buffoon